Primero quiero terminar el
debate de la clase pasada
sobre las reacciones desconcertantes
que generan los problemas del tranvía.
Recordarán que el problema del
tranvía es desconcertante
porque al parecer hay una
asimetría en nuestras respuestas
al caso del transeúnte y al
caso del hombre gordo,
aunque ambos parecen implicar matar a
1 persona para salvar a 5.
La clase pasada vimos la
respuesta de Judy Thomson,
que decía que no hay
asimetría en los 2 casos,
porque cuando reflexionamos en el
tercer caso hipotético
donde nosotros estábamos
parados en otra vía,
entendimos que no es moralmente
aceptable desviar el tranvía
en el caso del transeúnte
ni tampoco aventar al hombre gordo.
Por el contrario, vimos la respuesta
de Josh Greene, que decía
que así como es moralmente
aceptable desviar el tranvía
en el caso del transeúnte,
también es moralmente aceptable
aventar al hombre gordo.
Green dice que obtenemos respuestas
diferenciales en esos casos
porque se activa el mecanismo
de respuesta emocional
de nuestro cerebro, debido a la
naturaleza personal y cercana
del caso del hombre gordo,
y como resultado,
damos una respuesta que él
considera moralmente injustificada.
Al final de la clase empezamos a
considerar una tercera posibilidad,
que está entre las respuestas
de Thomson y de Greene,
aunque más cerca de la de Greene:
el argumento de Cass
Sunstein que dice que
aunque nuestras
respuestas sean distintas
y no las podamos cambiar,
en el fondo los casos son iguales.
Se inclina a pensar, aunque no
tanto como Josh Greene,
que si queremos asimilar los casos,
tenemos que aventar al hombre gordo.
Recordarán que su argumento decía:
En los casos no morales no resulta
polémico usar la heurística,
pero aunque esto sea útil,
con frecuencia nos lleva a errores.
Después, sostenía que así como
ocurre en los casos no morales
también ocurre en los casos morales.
Nos quedamos pensando al
final de la clase
en el argumento de Sunstein de
que en los casos morales
la gente suele usar la heurística.
Recordarán que Sunstein
dio algunos ejemplos
propuestos por Jonathan Haidt
donde la gente expresaba
su desaprobación moral
hacia ciertas acciones,
aunque no pudieran
justificar sus motivos.
Como el incesto
consentido entre hermanos
o limpiar el baño con una
bandera de Estados Unidos.
La gente tenía la inclinación a pensar
que eran casos moralmente
problemáticos,
aunque no eran capaces de explicar
qué regla moral se
violaba en esos casos.
Sunstein sugiere en su
texto que, en general,
podemos ver la literatura de la
heurística y del sesgo,
y descubrir que, en todos los
ejemplos, el marco del caso
influye en nuestra respuesta,
tanto en los casos no morales
como en los morales.
Recordarán que en la tercera clase,
cuando estábamos aprendiendo a
usar nuestros clickers,
por cierto, los vamos a usar
un poco en esta clase,
así que prepárenlos.
Cuando estábamos aprendiendo a
usar nuestros clickers,
vimos el famoso caso de la
enfermedad asiática,
que dice así:
Una terrible enfermedad ha atacado a
600 personas en su pueblo.
Hay 600 personas en su pueblo
destinadas a morir.
Ustedes son el alcalde y tienen
dos opciones disponibles:
el plan A o el plan B.
A la mitad del grupo le pedí que
mirara la descripción en verde:
en el plan A sobreviven 200 personas,
mientras que en el plan B hay
1/3 de probabilidad
de que 600 personas vivan y 2/3 de
probabilidad de que nadie viva.
La otra mitad del grupo miró
exactamente el mismo plan,
pero descrito en términos de
cuántas personas morirían
en vez de cuántas vivirían.
El plan A dice: vivirán
200 personas de 600,
es decir, morirán 400.
El plan A significa que
morirán 400 de 600 personas,
es decir, que vivirán 200 personas.
Esta fue nuestra primera
encuesta con clickers
y su actitud hacia los
casos fue distinta.
Cuando se presentaba el número de
personas que vivirían,
el 66% eligió el plan A y solo
el 34% eligió el plan B.
Cuando se invirtió el marco,
los resultados fueron
justamente al revés.
El 66% prefería el plan A
en el caso verde
y el 64% prefería el plan
A en el caso azul.
Pero los planes A y B son
idénticos matemáticamente.
Tal vez algo similar sucede en
los casos del tranvía.
Este no es un ejemplo real
para votación,
pero imagínense que se les
presenta el siguiente caso:
Un terrible tranvía se
dirige a toda velocidad
hacia 6 personas en su pueblo.
Ustedes son el alcalde y tienen 2
opciones para el tranvía:
el plan A y el plan B.
Les presento el plan A: se
salvará 1 persona,
es decir, que morirán 5 personas.
O el plan B: morirá 1 persona,
es decir, que se salvarán 5 personas.
Creo que hay cierta tendencia a
elegir el plan B en el caso azul
y el plan A en el caso verde.
Esto sirve para generalizar.
Tenemos distintas respuestas
dependiendo de dónde nos enfoquemos
en estos dilemas morales.
Veamos el caso de Josh Greene
del bebé que llora:
están encerrados en un sótano
con otras 19 personas
y su bebé llorando, están
rodeados por soldados enemigos
que los matarán si los encuentran.
El dilema de Greene es:
¿Asfixiarían a su bebé
para evitar que su llanto
atraiga a los soldados,
que sin duda matarían a los
20 si los encontraran?
Es un caso muy parecido al
de Jim y los indios,
pero con una premisa
incluso más dolorosa.
Si centran su atención en la idea
de poner su mano en la boca
del bebé que llora,
es prácticamente imposible juzgar
que esa acción sea
moralmente obligatoria.
Pero si redirigen su
atención, incluso un poco,
hacia la niña de 2 años que está a
su lado o al niño de 4 años
que está al lado de ella, o al
anciano que está en el rincón,
a todos los que morirán si
no asfixian al bebé,
su respuesta al caso cambia.
El cambio de sentido de nuestra
atención será algo endémico
en todos los casos de este estilo.
En cierta medida, solo somos
capaces de centrarnos
en una parte del mundo a la vez.
Esto ocasiona que sea
sumamente difícil centrarnos
de tal forma que este tipo de dilemas
morales parezcan estables.
Sunstein sugiere que debido
a este fenómeno
los rasgos tendrían que ser
moralmente irrelevantes.
No puede ser moralmente
relevante al decidir
qué es lo correcto en el
caso del tranvía
el enmarcarlo en términos de
cuántas personas vivirán
o cuántas morirán.
Por lo menos, a primera vista,
no parece algo que
podría ser relevante.
Están tomando exactamente
la misma decisión
enmarcada de 2 formas distintas.
¿Cómo podría ser que eso
marcara la diferencia?
Sunstein sugiere que el mecanismo
que hay detrás del fenómeno
que acabo de describir
sucede una y otra vez,
no solo en los casos hipotéticos como
los problemas del tranvía,
sino todo el tiempo en los
razonamientos morales
que hacemos como ciudadanos
de una democracia,
que intentan hacer juicios sobre la
distribución de recursos
y sobre el tipo de leyes
que debería haber
para regular o incentivar ciertos
tipos de comportamiento.
Sunstein afirma que en los
siguientes 4 dominios
con frecuencia nos centramos en
la heurística, es decir,
en los rasgos
superficiales del
fenómeno,
en vez de en los atributos de
destino, es decir,
en lo que realmente nos interesa.
Recuerden que la clase pasada
hablábamos de ponerle una
funda a sus teléfonos
para reconocerlos fácilmente
y así tener un acceso
heurístico a su teléfono.
Obviamente, esa decoración es
útil como un medio
para encontrar el teléfono
solo mientras sirva
para encontrar el atributo de
destino que les importa,
por ejemplo, encontrar el teléfono
que tiene los números de
contactos que les interesan.
Cuando los atributos de destino y la
heurística no coinciden,
estamos en problemas.
Sunstein se pregunta qué debemos hacer,
cuando pensamos en las
reglas de seguridad,
con el hecho de que como seres humanos
muchas cosas que hacemos tienen el
potencial de causar daño,
pero no queremos pasarnos nuestras
vidas envueltos en plástico,
caminando muy lento por el mundo
para no chocar contra nada.
Siendo que deseamos tomar riesgos,
¿cómo interactúa nuestra
tendencia a usar la heurística
con la regulación de los riesgos?
En el caso del castigo,
y este es el primer tema que veremos
después de las vacaciones,
Sunstein piensa que
usamos la heurística
de forma contraproducente
al castigar tanto a
individuos como a grupos.
Sunstein piensa que cuando
dudamos en ciertas decisiones
sobre medicina reproductiva,
corremos el riesgo
de confundir la heurística con
los atributos de destino.
Y al tomar muy en serio la distinción de
la omisión del acto, corremos
el riesgo de confundir la heurística
con los atributos de destino.
Volveremos al tema del castigo
después de las vacaciones
y al tema de la omisión del acto
más adelante en esta clase.
Ahora quiero explicar 3 ejemplos
de la regulación del riesgo
mediante el análisis de Sunstein.
El tercer ejemplo… tengo
mucha curiosidad
de ver cómo salen los
resultados de las encuestas.
Sunstein señala, y parece tener razón,
que es más probable que las
personas condenen a una empresa
cuando el comportamiento de esta
se describe con factores
que implican seguridad en vez de riesgo.
Por ejemplo, la empresa A
fabrica un producto que usarán
10 millones de personas,
pero matará a 10 personas.
De los 10 millones de personas
que usarán este producto,
10 tendrán una reacción de algún
tipo al producto y morirán.
El costo de eliminar ese riesgo por
completo sería de $100 millones.
Muchas personas se inclinan a pensar
que la empresa debería gastar ese
dinero para deshacerse del riesgo;
que es inaceptable que
fabrique un producto
que provocará la muerte de 10 personas.
En cambio, si enmarcamos el caso en
términos de probabilidades,
que 10 millones de personas
usan el producto,
que produce un riesgo de muerte
en 1 de cada 10 millones
y que la eliminación del riesgo
cuesta exactamente lo mismo,
este es el tipo de cosa que
permitimos todo el tiempo.
Sin esta tolerancia al riesgo no
habría innovaciones tecnológicas
y la mayoría de los bienes y recursos
que damos por sentado nunca
se habrían logrado.
Sunstein sostiene que
aunque en ambos casos los atributos
de destino son idénticos,
en este caso, 10 personas morirán
y salvarlos costaría $100 millones.
En este caso, 10 personas
morirán y salvarlos costaría
$100 millones, los atributos de
destino son idénticos.
En ambos casos 10 personas morirán
y salvarlos costaría la
cantidad especificada.
Los atributos
heurísticos son
distintos.
Este caso se enmarca en
términos de certeza;
este otro en términos de riesgo.
Y tenemos una buena
heurística que dice así:
Si 10 personas van a morir a
consecuencia de lo que ustedes hagan,
no lo hagan.
Sunstein sostiene que la
asimetría en nuestras respuestas
a estos casos es irracional.
De hecho, si en el segundo caso
aumentáramos el riesgo de muerte
de 1 a 2 personas por millón
y en el primer caso tuviéramos la
certeza de que mueren 10,
aun así la gente
condenaría el primer caso,
aunque el segundo caso sea
peor evidentemente.
Al confundir los atributos
heurísticos con los de destino,
permitimos comportamientos equivocados.
Sunstein piensa que esto
es lo que sucede
en el caso del comercio de
emisiones (límites y comercio)
del que fue uno de los
primeros defensores.
En el modelo de comercio de emisiones,
los contaminadores obtienen una licencia
para contaminar el aire
con "n" unidades.
Esas licencias se pueden comerciar en
el mercado de tal forma que
posiblemente haya menos
contaminación a menor costo.
Vamos conceder a Sunstein la razón
en el aspecto económico.
Aun así, hay oposición a los
límites y comercio.
Aunque estemos dispuestos a reconocer
que el atributo de destino
está presente,
es decir, que se ha reducido
la contaminación,
el atributo heurístico
nos parece problemático:
"¿La gente está pagando
por contaminar?
¡No se debería poder pagar para
librarse de una mala acción!".
Es un fenómeno interesante
que la oposición a este
tipo de razonamiento,
tanto de la izquierda como de la
derecha, dependa del contexto.
La izquierda se opone a
comercializar las cosas
y la derecha se resiste a cierto tipo
de marcos que sugieren que sus
respuestas a cuestiones
como las tecnologías
reproductivas y la clonación,
se deben, según Sunstein, a la
heurística de "no jugar a ser Dios".
Cuando se enfrentan a la
afirmación de que
"están usando la heurística", ambos
bandos responden con hostilidad
al sabihondo análisis académico.
En la década de los 70, era común
que los defensores de la
acumulación de arsenales nucleares
apelaran a la noción llamada
"destrucción mutua garantizada",
de la que hablaremos cuando
abordemos el dilema del prisionero.
La idea básica es que si ambos
lados tienen suficientes armas
para acabar con el enemigo,
ninguno de ellos las usará,
porque la disuasión es
bastante poderosa.
La izquierda se oponía a este análisis
porque parecía demasiado astuto.
Ambos bandos se oponen al
análisis de Sunstein,
porque va en contra de la idea
de que introspectivamente
seamos transparentes,
de que nuestros juicios sean indicativos
de las cosas que nos importan.
El último ejemplo que quiero
darles de Sunstein
es nuestra encuesta.
La hipótesis de Sunstein es...
¿Están funcionando sus clickers?
La hipótesis de Sunstein es
que nos incomoda más
que nos lastimen las cosas que se
supone que deben protegernos,
que las cosas cuya función
no sea protegernos.
Sugiere que hay datos que demuestran
que si a las personas se les da la
opción de elegir entre dos carros:
con el primer carro hay un
2% de probabilidad
de morir por el volante
si se accidentan.
Y en el segundo carro tienen
1% de probabilidad
de morir por el volante si se
accidentan, y además,
tienen 1/10 de 1% de probabilidad de
morir por la bolsa de aire.
La pregunta es: ¿Qué carro eligen?
El carro donde hay 2% de
probabilidad de morir por el
volante,
o el carro donde hay 1% de
probabilidad de morir por el volante
y 1/10 de 1% de probabilidad de
morir por la bolsa de aire,
que se supone que debía protegerlos.
Veamos los resultados.
Estoy haciendo esta encuesta
porque mis intuiciones no se alinearon
con lo que Sunstein propone
y me da curiosidad saber si
las de ustedes sí.
Veamos los resultados.
El 15% quiere comprar el carro A
y el 85% quiere comprar el carro B.
El 85% eligió
la opción racional estadísticamente.
Pero una buena parte están
dispuestos a arriesgarse más
para evitar ese sentimiento de
traición de la bolsa de aire,
que se supone que debía protegerlos.
Para resumir, Sunstein sugiere que
en el razonamiento moral,
con frecuencia, sustituimos los
atributos heurísticos
por los atributos de destino.
Y hacer esto es un error.
¿Qué sugieren las 3 respuestas
al problema del tranvía
que hemos considerado?
Thomson dice lo siguiente:
Reconsiderar nuestras intuiciones a
la luz de casos alternativos,
como el caso alternativo del transeúnte
donde nos imaginamos a nosotros
mismos en las vías,
puede hacernos cambiar
nuestra evaluación de dichos casos.
Ella considera que esos cambios
en nuestras respuestas
revelan algo significativo moralmente.
Podemos aprender al reflexionar
sobre esos casos específicos
qué es lo que la moralidad nos exige.
Greene y Sunstein, por el contrario,
afirman que nuestras respuestas
intuitivas a los casos
con frecuencia obedecen a aspectos que
son moralmente irrelevantes,
por lo tanto,
esos aspectos no revelan nada
significativo moralmente.
La pregunta es la siguiente:
¿Esto representa algún
problema para Mill y Kant?
Volvamos a las primeras páginas del
tratado sobre el utilitarismo de Mill.
No les pedí que le
leyeran este fragmento,
así que no hay razón para que
ya sepan lo que dice.
Mill escribe: "Aunque en la ciencia,
las verdades particulares
anteceden a la teoría general,
se puede esperar lo contrario en el
caso de las artes prácticas,
como la moral o la legislación."
En la ciencia, observamos
casos particulares.
Tiramos este objeto y cae con
una aceleración A,
tiramos este objeto y cae con
una aceleración A.
Entonces, concluimos que la ley que
gobierna la caída de los cuerpos
es que caen con una aceleración A.
"Aunque en la ciencia,
las verdades particulares
anteceden a la teoría general,
se puede esperar lo contrario en el
caso de las artes prácticas,
como la moral…
Una prueba del bien o el mal debe
ser un medio para determinar
lo que está bien o mal…
y no una consecuencia de ya
haberlo determinado".
Mill dice: "La dificultad" (de construir
una teoría a partir de juicios)
"no se evita por recurrir a"
lo que a veces se llama sentido moral,
"una facultad natural que
distingue lo bueno de lo malo
en un caso particular a mano,
mientras nuestros otros sentidos
perciben lo que se ve y se
escucha realmente".
Como si así pudieran ver si un
caso está mal moralmente.
"Más bien, el razonamiento
moral, la comprensión moral,
es una división de nuestra razón, no
de nuestra facultad emocional.
La moralidad de una
acción individual…
es una cuestión de la aplicación de
la ley a un caso individual…
Como resultado, cualquier
perseverancia o constancia
adquirida por nuestras creencias morales
se debe a una influencia tácita de este
estándar disponible reflexivamente".
Mill está construyendo teoría a partir de
teoría, no teoría a partir de casos.
Kant: "No puede prestarse peor
servicio a la moralidad
que un intento de hacer que se
derive de ejemplos.
Porque cada ejemplo de
moralidad en sí mismo
debe tener los principios
de la moralidad
para ver si puede funcionar
como un modelo".
De cierta manera, hemos expresado
aquí el diálogo de este curso.
¿En qué medida nuestra
capacidad de reflexión racional
es la mejor manera de responder a las
preguntas que nos interesan?
¿En qué medida nuestra capacidad
de respuesta emocional,
de sensación, de juicio instintivo
basado en la presentación de
casos particulares,
es indicativa de las respuestas a las
preguntas que nos interesan?
Con esto concluimos el debate de
los casos del tranvía.
En la segunda parte de la clase
quiero repasar 2 tipos de acertijos
que persisten sin importar cuál de
esas 2 actitudes adoptemos.
El primer acertijo es un pagaré
que les prometí en la primera clase,
porque es uno de los textos
más divertidos que vamos a
leer en todo el semestre.
Es el documento de Roy Sorensen
y Christopher Boorse
sobre agacharse o sacrificar.
Recordarán que ese fin de semana
habían disparado al senador de Arizona
y no quise dar el ejemplo con balas.
El ejemplo que les di es que
estaban parados en una fila.
Ustedes son la persona amarilla.
Un oso corre hacia ustedes
a toda velocidad.
Ustedes se quitan de la fila
y el oso se come a la persona
que tenían detrás.
Comparen esto con otro caso donde
están parados en la fila.
También aquí son la persona amarilla.
Un oso va corriendo en su dirección.
Ustedes se voltean, toman a
la persona de atrás
y la ponen enfrente de ustedes,
y el oso se la come.
El primero es el caso
clásico de agacharse.
Están en una situación
en la que un peligro
viene hacia ustedes.
Ustedes se quitan del camino del daño
y el daño va contra alguien más.
El segundo es un caso
clásico de sacrificio.
Un daño se dirige hacia ustedes
y usan a otra persona como
escudo para protegerse.
Agacharse es evitar un daño
y permitir que caiga sobre alguien más.
El sacrificio es evitar un daño
haciendo que caiga sobre alguien más,
usando a otra persona como un escudo.
Esto es análogo a la distinción
de la omisión del acto,
que ya vimos,
pero que está completamente
dentro del reino de los actos.
Sorensen y Boorse destacan
en su artículo
lo resistente que es este fenómeno
aunque se cambien los
marcos de los casos.
Presentan el ejemplo del pistolero
en el centro comercial.
Hay una bala dirigiéndose hacia ustedes
y tienen la opción de quitarse
o de poner a alguien enfrente de
ustedes para evitar la bala.
Está el caso del camión a
exceso de velocidad.
Están en una fila de carros.
Hay un camión que viene desde
atrás a tal velocidad
que chocará contra ustedes.
Tienen 2 opciones.
La primera es cambiarse de carril
y el camión chocará con el carro
que está enfrente de ustedes.
La segunda es hacerle una
señal al carro de atrás
para que se pase al carril
donde están ustedes
y el camión choque contra él.
Está el caso de los terroristas.
Están en un avión.
En este ejemplo, unos terroristas libios
-es bastante oportuno
hablar de Libia ahora-
están en el mismo avión
y amenazan con matar a todos
los estadounidenses.
Ustedes son representantes
del Departamento de Estado de
los Estados Unidos
y su portafolio tiene una etiqueta
del Departamento de Estado.
Los terroristas van por el pasillo y
están a punto de dispararles.
Tienen 2 posibilidades.
La primera, es cubrir su etiqueta con
otra de la aerolínea libia,
así los terroristas los ignorarán
y dispararán a la mujer que
está detrás en la fila.
La otra opción es cambiar su
portafolio con la persona de al lado
para que le disparen a ella
en vez de a ustedes.
O el caso de los barcos hundiéndose.
Están en el océano.
Están intentando obtener su señal,
su barco y el barco de al lado
se están hundiendo.
Están intentando enviar su señal
a un avión que está
sobrevolando para que los
rescate.
Tienen 2 opciones.
Pueden aumentar su señal, ¿verdad?
Hacer que su luz sea muy fuerte y que
el avión venga a rescatarlos.
O pueden interferir la
señal del otro barco
para que su señal sea un
poco más fuerte
y el avión venga a
rescatarlos a ustedes.
Sorensen presenta varios
casos como estos.
Si los escarabajos se están
comiendo sus rosas,
está bien usar insecticida
para que los escarabajos se
vayan a la casa del vecino,
pero no está bien poner atrayente
de escarabajos en sus rosas.
Tenemos esta extraña
tendencia, una y otra vez,
a pensar que está bien
agacharnos, pero no protegernos.
Sorensen y Boorse
consideran desconcertante
que parezca que no hay una
forma sistemática
para explicar este tipo de
discrepancias en la intuición.
Podrían pensar...
El problema con estos casos
es que cuando amarran los
zapatos de su oponente,
cuando intentan escaparse del oso,
o cuando ponen a otra persona
enfrente en el caso de las balas,
piensan que están
interfiriendo de forma justa.
Y que la competencia justa es lo
importante en este tipo de circunstancias.
Obviamente, en muchas de
estas circunstancias
la competencia era injusta
desde el principio.
Sin embargo, parece problemático.
Aunque la persona que están
intentando dejar atrás ante el oso
sea más lenta corriendo y tengan la
certeza de que le ganarán,
sigue pareciendo incorrecto
amarrarle sus zapatos entre sí.
No parece que la justicia
de la competencia
sea lo que impulse la intuición.
Dicen que tal vez, en todos
los casos de empujones,
lo que hacen ustedes es una
especie de mal incluido.
Está mal agarrar a alguien y
ponerlo adelante de ustedes.
Pero está bien solo agacharse para que
algo le pegue a otra persona.
Está mal robar el
portafolio de alguien.
Está mal interferir la
señal de alguien.
Señalan que al parecer es igual de malo
poner a otra persona enfrente de
ustedes de forma amigable
preguntándole si quiere
apreciar la hermosa vista.
Es igual de malo que agarrarla y
ponerla delante de ustedes.
Asustar a alguien
para que salte de un
acantilado gritándole "E=mc2"
es igual de problemático que
sorprenderlo para que salte
gritándole algún apodo racial.
No parece que el mal incluido
explique nuestra respuesta.
Dejaré que lean estas
respuestas por su cuenta
si aún no han podido hacerlo.
Tampoco parece que la distinción
de la omisión del acto,
ni la distinción de la aceptación del
acto basten como explicación.
Tampoco parece bastar la idea
de que sea importante
si fueron el locus de una cadena causal,
los creadores de alguna
secuencia de causalidad.
La doctrina del efecto doble
tampoco parece explicar estos casos.
Tampoco parece que la noción
de los derechos de Kant
comparada con la noción
utilitaria expliquen estos casos.
Sorensen y Boorse concluyen
no muy satisfechos
y con escepticismo que:
es un rasgo desconcertante
sobre nuestra psicología.
Pero nosotros, habiendo escuchado la
primera mitad de esta clase,
tenemos otra explicación alternativa.
No les garantizo que
funcionará en todos los casos,
pero parece bastante prometedora.
Esta explicación dice que en los
casos de agacharse o protegerse
hay un exceso de aplicación
de la heurística.
En general, parece que quitarse
del camino de un daño
no es algo malo,
mientras que poner a alguien en
el camino de un daño
sí es malo.
Tal vez, este primer
conjunto de acertijos
se puede explicar mediante
la heurística.
En estos 15 minutos quiero centrarme
en una serie de acertijos
que pienso que no pueden explicarse
mediante la heurística.
Para esto, vamos a
necesitar los clickers.
Comencemos con cuatro conductores.
El primero es Alberto
Afortunado o Atento Afortunado,
que hace lo siguiente:
Se sube a su carro.
Tiene su carro en perfecto estado.
Respeta todos los semáforos.
Maneja de forma sumamente segura.
Y al final del día vuelve a su
casa después del trabajo.
Eso es todo. Ese es Atento Afortunado.
Pregunta: Cuando Atento
Afortunado maneja hacia su casa,
sin tomar en cuenta que lleva a
su amante en su carro,
sin tomar en cuenta que compró un carro
que produce altas emisiones en
vez de uno híbrido.
Al manejar hacia su casa,
sin tomar en cuenta
todas las otras cosas que Atento
podría haber hecho mal moralmente,
¿hizo algo reprobable moralmente al
ir del trabajo a su casa,
al tener en buenas condiciones su carro
y no lastimar a nadie en el camino?
No es una pregunta con trampa.
Si piensan que Atento Afortunado
hizo algo reprobable
moralmente al conducir,
sin tomar en cuenta todas las cosas
que son reprobables
moralmente, pulsen 1.
Si piensan que no hizo nada
reprobable moralmente,
pulsen 2.
Están juzgando la acción de
manejar del trabajo a la casa,
si no pasa nada malo,
¿es una acción
problemática moralmente?
Esperemos que...
Siempre hay este 5%.
Esas multitudes que están en
contra de los carros.
Son los que irán a la
escuela de medicina
y descuartizarán a una pobre persona
sana en la sala de espera.
El 95% piensa que Atento Afortunado
no hizo nada reprobable moralmente.
Conozcamos al gemelo de Atento
Afortunado, Atento Desafortunado.
Aquí está lo que hizo
Atento Desafortunado.
Exactamente lo mismo que
Atento Afortunado.
Excepto que cerca de su casa,
un niño corrió enfrente de su
carro y lo atropelló.
¿De acuerdo? Atento Desafortunado
hizo exactamente lo mismo que
Atento Afortunado.
Salió del trabajo, revisó sus
llantas, estuvo atento todo el tiempo
y manejó a una velocidad
segura y adecuada.
Pero debido a su mala suerte, mató
a un niño en el camino.
Pregunta: ¿Atento Desafortunado hizo
algo reprobable moralmente?
Pulsen 1 si consideran que sí.
Pulsen 2 si consideran que no.
Voy a apuntar los resultados
del primer caso: 5 y 95.
Ok. Veamos los resultados.
El 81% piensa que no hizo nada
reprobable moralmente,
pero pasamos del 5%
al 19% que piensa que sí hizo
algo reprobable moralmente.
Pasemos a nuestro tercer caso.
Aquí tenemos al Sr. Celular Afortunado.
Esto es lo que hace el Sr.
Celular Afortunado.
Se sube a su carro y maneja
del trabajo a su casa.
Y en el camino del trabajo a su
casa habla en su celular,
pero no pasa nada.
Llega a su casa sin haber
lastimado a nadie.
Pregunta: ¿Celular Afortunado hizo
algo reprobable moralmente
al hablar por teléfono
mientras manejaba?
Veamos los resultados.
Ok. Este es su veredicto:
El 78% piensa que Celular
Afortunado hizo algo…
¡No puedo creerlo!
¡Se están adelantando al
siguiente caso!
Todos ustedes hablan en sus celulares
cuando van manejando todo el tiempo
y no piensan que están haciendo
algo reprobable moralmente.
Ok. Estos datos no son válidos.
Esto se debe a dónde están
insertados en este experimento.
Bien.
Como ya respondieron a la
cuarta pregunta,
déjenme preguntarles si...
Celular Desafortunado maneja
del trabajo a su casa
hablando por teléfono.
Un niño corre enfrente de su carro y…
Pregunta:
¿Celular Desafortunado hizo
algo reprobable moralmente
en su camino a casa?
Veamos los resultados.
Bien.
Veamos cómo sale la gran barra roja
de Celular Desafortunado.
Ok. Tenemos un cambio total
comparado con el caso original
y también es diferente
del caso anterior.
Ok.Estos ejemplos demuestran
un fenómeno conocido como suerte moral.
Tenemos dos personas, Atento
Afortunado y Atento Desafortunado,
que hacen exactamente lo mismo,
pero las acciones de
Atento Desafortunado
causan la muerte de una
víctima inocente.
Mientras solo el 5% piensa
que Atento Afortunado hizo algo malo,
el 19% piensa que Atento
Desafortunado hizo algo malo.
Tenemos algo similar,
alguien que de forma muy sutil
ha tomado un riesgo,
que en un caso no tuvo
malas consecuencias
y en el otro tuvo graves consecuencias.
El 92% condena a Celular Desafortunado.
Esto ilustra el fenómeno
conocido como suerte moral.
Los casos donde un agente
recibe una culpa moral
por una acción o sus consecuencias
aunque dicho agente no
tenga control total
sobre la acción o sus consecuencias.
¿De acuerdo? No es que Atento
Desafortunado y Celular Desafortunado
quisieran que el niño corriera
enfrente de sus carros.
No es que Atento Desafortunado y
Celular Desafortunado
hubieran podido hacer algo
distinto en ese momento.
El niño estaba enfrente del carro
y el carro lo atropelló.
La suerte moral es desconcertante
porque parece que tenemos 2
compromisos que compiten entre sí
cuando pensamos en la
responsabilidad moral.
Por un lado, parece que aceptamos el
llamado principio de control
de que no debería asignarse
mérito ni culpa moral
en los casos donde la acción
o las consecuencias
están más allá del
control del agente.
Puedo ver que la mayoría de ustedes se
suscribe al principio del control,
porque el 81% piensan que
Atento Desafortunado
no hizo nada malo moralmente,
aunque haya matado a un
niño con su carro.
La razón por la que se
inclinan a pensar
que no hizo nada malo,
sospecho que se debe
a que su juicio en ese caso,
como decía Mill,
está regulado por un principio al
que se suscriben tácitamente.
Concretamente, algo como el
principio de control.
Nagel dice que es
verosímil intuitivamente
que la gente no pueda ser
evaluada moralmente
por algo que no es su culpa
o que se debe a factores que van
más allá de su control.
Si chocan contra mí y me tropiezo,
y accidentalmente caigo encima del
botón rojo que va a ocasionar
el inicio de la guerra nuclear en
el planeta, no es mi culpa.
Es horrible que el planeta
quede destruido,
pero yo solo me tropecé.
Por el contrario,
directamente en competencia
con el principio del control, el
principio de la suerte moral estipula,
que en algunos casos,
el mérito y la culpa
moral deben asignarse
aunque la acción o sus consecuencias
estén más allá del
control del agente.
La diferencia en nuestras respuestas
entre los casos afortunados
y desafortunados
indica el grado en el que nos
suscribimos tácitamente a eso.
Pasaron del 95% al 81% de no reprobable.
El 15% cambió su opinión
por algo que está más allá
del control del agente.
En el caso del celular,
más o menos el 15% cambió de opinión.
El problema es que es muy difícil
deshacerse de ambos principios.
El principio del control se basa en el
siguiente tipo de razonamiento.
Por lo general, tenemos un
sentido bastante bueno
de qué tipo de factores aumentan la
culpa o el mérito de una acción.
Por lo general, si una
acción es involuntaria,
si no se hace por
coacción ni por error.
Si eligen específicamente realizar
la acción que han realizado,
obtendrán más mérito por hacerla
si fue una buena acción
y más culpa si fue una mala acción.
De la misma forma, si contaban
con toda la información,
si eran conscientes de las
consecuencias posibles,
si sabían que lo que daban de beber a
alguien era agua o cianuro,
esto aumenta el grado de
mérito o de culpa.
Estas son respuestas bastante sólidas
que van en contra no solo de
nuestro análisis de casos,
sino también de nuestra
comprensión de los principios
que parecen sustentar la
responsabilidad moral.
De la misma manera, parece que la
ausencia de esas características
disminuye la culpa o el mérito moral.
Si hacen algo bajo coacción
o accidentalmente,
tienen menos responsabilidad.
Si hacen algo por falta de
información, por ejemplo,
si pienso que les estoy dando algo
completamente saludable
y termino dándoles algo
que les hace daño,
solemos pensar que el grado
de culpa se mitiga.
El principio del control
simplemente dice
que si no hubiera una
diferencia en estos factores,
¿cómo podría haber una diferencia
en la culpa o el mérito?
Si estos factores se
mantuvieran constantes,
estaríamos en una situación
en la que no habría diferencia en
la responsabilidad moral.
Por el contrario, el principio de la suerte
moral también es bastante fuerte.
Parece innegable que en
algunos casos evaluamos
el mérito moral y la culpa en
la ausencia de control.
Como el caso del conductor.
Uno de los sujetos que usan el celular
atropella al niño, el otro no.
Al primero se le culpa moralmente.
Dejo la estufa prendida en mi
casa o en su casa.
Voy a visitarlos y dejo la
estufa prendida en su casa.
Salgo de la casa todo el día.
Cuando no tengo suerte,
la casa se quema.
Cuando tengo suerte no se quema.
Al parecer, aunque piensen que
ambas cosas son malas,
es peor dejar la estufa
prendida y quemar la casa
que dejar la estufa
prendida simplemente.
Nagel da el ejemplo de dejar la
tina llenándose de agua
con el bebé adentro.
Es una acción muy irresponsable,
pero mucho más problemática
cuando el bebé se ahoga.
O el caso en el que ustedes y yo
tenemos carácteres similares.
Yo me quedo en Alemania, ustedes no.
Es la década de 1930. Me vuelvo nazi;
ustedes viven sin las
exigencias morales nazis.
Hay 3 tipos de respuestas
que podemos dar
a los casos de suerte moral.
Podemos ofrecer una
respuesta racionalista.
Podemos decir que la suerte
simplemente no puede jugar un papel
en la evaluación moral.
Podemos adoptar el extremo de eso,
una visión meramente kantiana
de que el agente solo es
responsable de su voluntad
y de aquellas cosas sobre las que
tiene un control total.
O pueden adoptar una
versión extrema de Mill.
Que el agente es responsable de
todas las consecuencias
de sus acciones y que la actitud no
hace ninguna diferencia.
Pueden adoptar una actitud
irracional hacia esto.
Pueden decir
que la suerte puede jugar un papel
en la evaluación moral.
Aunque pienso que esta opción es
muy difícil de mantener,
podrían decir que nunca
sabemos qué tan responsable
es una persona de una acción hasta
que vemos sus consecuencias.
Que cuando hacía la hipótesis de que
estos casos eran idénticos,
estaba idealizando de forma ilegítima.
Parece que la tercera
respuesta podría funcionar
para los casos clásicos de suerte
moral que he estado describiendo,
casos que podríamos considerar
de suerte resultante,
en los que hay suerte en el
resultado de la acción.
Realizo una acción que fracasa de
una forma que yo no esperaba.
Ese es un tipo de caso de suerte moral.
Pero es difícil ver cómo
podemos usar esa explicación
para algunos casos más profundos.
Consideremos la suerte constitutiva.
Algunos de ustedes nacieron con genes
que les facilitan comportarse
de forma altruista,
algunos no.
Algunos fueron criados en familias
que apoyaban ciertos aspectos morales
y algunos no.
Si su carácter es el
resultado de esos aspectos,
¿ustedes son responsables de eso?
En caso de que no, ¿por qué el
mérito o la culpa moral
se evalúan con respecto al carácter?
Consideremos la suerte circunstancial,
que Jonathan Shay discutía en
Achilles in Vietnam,
la suerte con respecto al
entorno del agente.
A veces, las circunstancias en
las que se encuentran
crean o revelan aspectos
ocultos de su carácter.
Debido a que son en parte una
cuestión de suerte, ¿eso significa
que ustedes no son moralmente
responsables de lo que hicieron?
Por último, si pensamos en
nuestras acciones
desde la perspectiva del libre
albedrío, se vuelve difícil encontrar
un espacio en el que seamos
responsables de lo que hacemos.
Es un aspecto general del mundo que las
acciones y las consecuencias
están determinadas en parte
por aspectos externos,
que están fuera del control del agente.
Comenzamos a pensar por qué
respondemos de esa manera
en los casos del tranvía y
resulta que se debe
a que se activa nuestra parte
emocional del cerebro.
¿Por qué pasa eso?
Porque el flujo de sangre
sucede de cierta forma
en nuestro cerebro.
¿Y por qué pasa eso?
Porque la sangre fluye de cierta manera
por las acciones de cierto
tipo de moléculas.
A medida que reflexionamos sobre
esto, la zona de agencia,
dice Nagel, parece encogerse
a un punto infinito.
Dejo que se vayan de vacaciones
con la siguiente
no-solución desconcertante
a un problema moral profundo.
Nagel sugiere que el problema de la
suerte no tiene solución
porque algo en la idea de
concebirnos como agentes
es incompatible con el hecho innegable
de que las acciones son eventos y
las personas son cosas.
"A medida que los determinantes
externos de la acción de alguien
exponen gradualmente su efecto
en las consecuencias,
en el carácter y en la misma
elección, vemos que efectivamente
las acciones son eventos y las
personas son cosas.
Como resultado,
no queda nada que pueda imputarse
al sujeto responsable,
y nos quedamos solo con una
porción de una larga secuencia
de eventos que puede
lamentarse o celebrarse,
pero no puede ser objeto de
mérito o de culpa".
Sin embargo, renunciar al
lenguaje del mérito o la culpa
es eliminar de nuestro
repertorio conceptual
tal vez la herramienta más
importante que tenemos.
Llegar a una perspectiva
estable de estos asuntos
parece sumamente difícil.
Nos vemos después de las vacaciones.